do you know one time when jacob was like
two
and joey was used to stay at my house a
bunch jacob used to love things that
made noises
sure and he liked the maracas they
needed to walk around with maracas
and his little underwear he'd watch
blue's clues and go yeah
and so one day i was in the kitchen and
he was uh i heard him
and i was like what is going on and i
walked out there and he had two little
baggies of coke that made
noise that had fallen out of somebody's
pocket probably joey's
stayed at the house probably
and i was like hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy hey bud let's not open those
that's not that's not kool-aid papa why
don't you go ahead and hand those yeah
[ __ ] crazy yeah have you talked to
joey since he's been out oh yeah
jersey hell yeah he's happy is he happy
he's
happier than a he's not very poor though
right he's because of the covetous he's
still worried about coving no
it's not that it's not he just want a
break
it's not that either i think he is
trying to figure out how much he wants
to tour
ever again i think that's it you know
man that'd be taking a break though
technically right like you're welcome
stopping from doing it all together so
you know he used to keep this both of us
he used to just keep a notebook every
time you went on stage
and what the jokes you did how long you
did it where you performed what you
think worked and didn't work
and joey would set a goal for himself
monthly gigs
and i i think monthly gigs for a while
there
he was setting the goal for 45 cents a
month
40 45 cents a month that's including the
spots at the store or wherever
45 sets a month whether it's 10 15 an
hour
just counting those 45 sets yeah a total
45 mics right
and he did that and not only that dude
you know he was doing at a time where he
didn't have a car yep
people used to tell me all the time i
think there's like five joe diaz's
because i see one walking down the
street
in every part of this city and if you
add that up
you know he was saying the other day he
was like i'm just
i'm burnt i've just done it so much i
get it
and that year off the year off man made
a lot of us
rethink and i didn't take a year i
didn't take a full year off yeah but
still it forced us to be like hold up
hold up man
what am i doing you guys are out of your
mind yeah you you i know you want to
book me four weeks a month but
what it's yeah and it's a lot of
diminishing if you have kids
like tom segura told me like you know he
because i
i you know i think comes out two beers
one cave it's me and sagura
and i'm like dude you're a guy like i
never saw you around like the store
all the time like the other guys like i
come from the joe rogan
blueprint where it's like set set set
set sets and i was known as like a
stagehound where
if there was an open mic i'm there man
just call me uh
i'm your guy so i was doing four or five
sets every night monday through thursday
then friday on tour so
full hour two shows friday two show
saturday back home sunday back to the
race
on monday and i was like tom you weren't
like that he's like well when i was
younger i was he's like but dude as you
do it like i build my hour on the road
man i'm
you have kids dude so i'm not i'm not
out at night dude if i am you know every
once in a while i'd come out and you
guys would see me but
i'm building the hour on the road and
that's what joe coy did it never made
sense to my god they're just not working
no they
are but they're also present in their
kids lives that's
you know so a lot of
people like the generation of comics
before me
i mean after me i've heard a lot of them
say
recently because we look man i was the
same way i was raising kids
so i wasn't hanging out at the store no
i was going to do my and i'm a grown-up
bro
what am i hanging out that nothing good
is happening from hanging out maybe a
couple chats with some of the guys my
hangouts here yeah yeah
and that green room for 10 15 minutes
beforehand and messing around and
talking gravity is great
but if you're there till two in the
morning nothing good is coming out of
that especially you have kids you gotta
be up at six what were you doing yeah
man it
and it's again i'm taking two hours out
of their lives
so i can talk to whoever the [ __ ] about
your set
i don't think so yeah and so i i had a
bunch of comics they were like yeah we
always thought you were just kind of
aloof yeah and i was like no
and they said as we got older we
realized that you just had
[ __ ] to do yeah priorities dude i had
three kids sitting at the house
commitments yeah yeah so it but but
hashtag good